wilmington north carolina's police chief
has fired three veteran officers for
what he calls
hate filled speech caught on a patrol
car
camera internal investigation accused
officers
kevin piner and brian gilmore and
corporal jesse moore
of violating standards of conduct and
using inappropriate slurs
including the n-word investigators say
that piner described killing black
people in a new civil war
saying quote wipe them off the leap map
david bagnow spoke to the chief about
this and david he's taking this
beyond his department he's sending quite
a message
he sure is gail good morning donnie
williams is the first black police chief
for the wilmington north carolina police
department and this week was his first
day on the job
and do you know what the first thing was
that he did on his first day
he fired these officers chief one of the
officers
wanted to resign but you said no i'm
gonna fire you
why because um people are tired of
officers being involved in misconduct
and walking away quietly
i wanted to fire them to make sure that
their chances of being rehired again
were minimized these individuals do not
deserve to be in law enforcement
documents released by the wilmington
police department state that the
conversations were discovered during a
routine video audit of
officer piner's patrol car he is heard
telling corporal moore that he is quote
ready for a civil war and plan to buy an
assault rifle to quote
start slaughtering them inwards during a
phone call moore refers to a woman who
he claims was resisting arrest
as the n-word multiple times and he says
she needed a bullet in her head right
then did these officers try to fight you
on releasing their files they did do you
have any indication
that anyone at any point tried to
put this to the side so it wouldn't
embarrass your agency
no they brought it to my attention
immediately once they found it
according to the investigators each
officer admitted it was their voice on
the video
but blamed their comments on the stress
of the job arising from the stress of
today's climate in law enforcement
cbs news reached out to the police union
and the three officers for comment
but never heard back it's one thing to
fire the officers
but you want more than that you want to
foreseeably prevent them from working in
law enforcement
again in the state of north carolina
correct that is correct
um normally when um officers are
involved in misconduct
they'll resign and they'll slip away
quietly and in some cases they'll
be able to maintain their certification
and get a job with another agency
in this case these individuals do not
deserve to be in law enforcement
chief williams even asked the district
attorney to review cases that the three
fired officers have been involved in to
look for biases
the d.a told cbs news 89 cases are under
review
and some have already been thrown out do
you think
you need more people who are black to be
on your force
i will say yes we also need more females
to be on that force
but the color of a person's skin
is not going to determine the color of
their heart you have
white officers that are good officers
you have white officers that are bad
officers you have black officers that
are good officers and you also have
black officers that are bad officers
so the color of their heart is more
important to me than the color of the
skin
boy how much do we love chief williams
that's such a good point me we all take
that message from him
but i got to tell you david listening to
those words was so hard to hear even
though they were
bleeped out that that is a police
officer on the force
who is who is supposedly to protect and
serve all of us
that's very tough to hear and painful
and painful thank
you thankfully it doesn't represent all
officers gail and would be great to have
a chief williams in every department
around the country
yes yes yes you could take notes from
how chief williams operates thank you
very much david